it is new year's eve normally there's  what 300 000 people in las vegas for  this holiday  a smaller crowd is expected this year  for obvious reasons  no live entertainment plan for downtown  right now the fremont street experience  is still planning to be open you're  looking at the website right now for the  experience  now they've limited capacity there and  the wristbands cost  25 but as you see here when we click on  the link to buy the tickets  it shows that it says that it is  temporarily offline we're not exactly  sure what that means  but if you're trying to buy tickets or a  wristband to go to the fremont street  experience  it's not going to work for you this  morning we'll have keep an eye on that  certainly  state leaders have criticized plans to  allow crowds on the fremont street  experience  tonight